Speaker 1: All right. Final event we're going
to cover from the weekend is the day after. On
Sunday, Trump did another rally in Florida, Miami,
Florida, for Marco Rubio. He did not rally for
Ron DeSantis. Ron DeSantis was not invited,
although Trump did say reelect Ron DeSantis
after people were mad that he called them Ron to
sanctimonious. The energy was particularly scary
at this one. Now, often at the rallies, Trump is
sweating and dripping, but this one actually had
pouring rain. We'll get to that in a moment. Scary
energy and Trump starting with Nancy Pelosi, whose
husband recently needed skull surgery because
of a lunatic right wing attacker who bashed his
head in with a skull. Listen to what Trump says.
Speaker 2: This is this was just a cabal. This was
just a group of people where crazy. Nancy Pelosi,
by the way, how's she doing lately? How she's
doing. We're crazy. Nancy Pelosi has of us.
Speaker 1: How is she doing? She's probably
extremely traumatized from what one of Trump's
followers did to her husband, and then even more
disgusting, they start chanting, Lock her up
about Nancy Pelosi. She hasn't been charged or
she's not even being investigated for a crime.
Speaker 2: Up and down the ballot, Republican.
And we're going to end crazy Nancy Pelosi's
political career once and for. Once again
under Biden, Pelosi, Schumer and
the radical Democrat Congress,
Florida workers and families are under siege.
Speaker 1: Lock her up. Right. I mean,
they're for due process and law and order and
lock up a woman who's not even being investigated
for any crime. Truly, truly dangerous.
Trump then did his racist dog whistle
about Mitch McConnell's wife, Elaine Chao.
Speaker 2: And I say, you got to get Mitch
McConnell to be a lot tougher than you, McConnell.
You can have Mitch McConnell and his wife,
Coco. Coco Chao. You can have them both.
Speaker 1: Coco Chao is Trump's latest
sort sort of xenophobic dog whistle about Elaine
Chao. Horrifying stuff. And the crowd just I mean,
totally, completely unfazed by it. Trump did,
as I mentioned, get enough backlash about saying
run to sanctimonious about Ron DeSantis on
Saturday night. So by yesterday afternoon,
he did the absolute bare minimum and was like,
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Reelect Ron DeSantis. Governor.
Speaker 2: Are you going to reelect Ron
DeSantis as your governor here in the state?
Speaker 1: He did it. He held his nose,
but he did it. And then we'll talk about
this in a different context. But Donald Trump also
talking about how much suffering there has been
for his own children. Imagine that
they are the real victims here.
Speaker 2: And a man who I just happened to catch
about half of his speech, I got in and I said,
who's ripping it up there? And it
was a person named donald trump jr.
And he's great and he's great. You know, I have
to tell this one story because he said I guess I
could tell he's probably heard me tell it a couple
of times that much. But to show you how evil these
people are. So Don went to great school. He
went to the Wharton School of Finance. All
this to have good students. He was great. He was
no problem whatsoever. He's just a good young guy.
And I decided to go into politics. I said, you
know, life is too good. Everything's perfect.
Let's screw up your life a little bit, okay?
And so I take my family along with me and they,
you know, they've really suffered
when you think of it. But they
they don't have any second questions or.
Speaker 1: That they've really suffered.
His family really made the sacrifice.
Donald Trump does tease that he might
announce his candidacy for president
tonight, which we'll talk about later.
Speaker 2: I will probably have
to do it again, but stay tuned.
Speaker 1: It's quite a cult
here, as you can imagine.
And then he drops this about Ohio tonight.
Speaker 2: That's pretty good. Thank you.
Stay tuned to tomorrow night. In
the great state of Ohio. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there's a report that Trump's
going to announce next Monday. We'll talk
about that in a moment. And then lastly,
it quite literally started pouring during
the rally and Donald Trump made a big deal out
of the fact that he was heroically staying out
there to speak to his followers.
Speaker 2: To rival our own. And
just two years ago.
Unidentified: We had a real.
China, Russia and North Korea share.
Speaker 2: They weren't going to do anything.
Speaker 1:
Anyway, it was pouring and Trump was soaked and
they all made a big deal out of how heroic it was
to stay out there. These rallies are extremely
dangerous. The people are weaponized. Today,
we will have competing rallies.
Barack Obama and Trump. Trump's
in Ohio. I forget where Obama is. We will
have them live later. Okay. We're going to
take a quick break. If you watch us on
YouTube and you're not yet subscribed,
make sure to subscribe. Subscribe to the
podcast. And we'll be back right after this.